when Will trump make a peep about his
choice for
vep as Donald sails toward the GOP
nomination there's growing speculation
who could be his number two which is
very different than Biden's handlers
discussing his number
twos as oh that's too easy as the New
York Post reported over the weekend
Trump's team had reached out to RFK Jr
early on about serving as VP they quote
wouldn't write it off well it certainly
would prove true the old saying politics
makes for strange bed fellows something
I remembered whenever I woke up next to
B
Arthur
Rip but despite that report a top Trump
Aid said it's 100% fake news no one from
the campaign ever approached RFK Jr or
ever will and it would also require RFK
to switch affiliation again as he's
already been a Democrat an independent
and a member of Planet
Fitness so like Jerry nadler's penis
when he looks down the VP Choice remains
to be
seen sorry I
apologize of course there are other
candidates on the short list like vake
who's been seen on campaign stops with
Trump after dropping out of the race but
for all we know though Trump's actual
choice for VP could be hiding in VI's
hair South Dakota governor Christy gnome
she's got the looks of Marie Osman and
as a wartime leader she kept the peace
between South and North Dakota
there's also jie Vance Tulsi Gabbert
Elise stefanic but who else could he
pick are there any other out there that
would be worth mentioning how about Ted
nent huh y yeah antifa definitely won't
attack the White House a Lincoln even in
his present condition he'll run circles
around
kamla Barbie she's got more brains in
her head than kamla and less plastic in
her face than
Pelosi
and of course Brian
kilme that guarantees no one will ever
want to take out
[Laughter]
Trump who's that what's that mean the
moaning all right Andrew who would you
like to see as VP have you thought about
it well I mean already considering that
Biden effectively has Taylor Swift as
his VP but you know Trump's got to go
outside the realm of reality he got to
do it's sexy red maybe or uh you know
I'm think like 50 c because that's what
a dollar's worth now in this
economy it is interesting how people in
the hipop world are moving towards Trump
trump doesn't have to do anything just
be himself and the world comes to him
Kat the one thing I liked about RFK was
that he never blamed the voters for
their preferences like he was genuinely
seem to understand Trump voters or be
interested in how they felt yeah and the
fact that he's not a republican I don't
think really would make that much of a
difference I I mean Trump isn't a
republican by the standard of what a
republican was before Trump entered
politics I mean he completely changed
everything so I don't think that really
makes any difference yeah I I'm now
already thinking about a trump sexy red
ticket I think we're the only people who
know who she is so I'm sorry that you
guys don't get it um cuz that was really
really funny but I don't think it's
going to be Mike Pence I know who sexy
red is
I know who sexy red is I love the
gum um good for you thank you Kaylee uh
does it matter who he picks it's just
trump it it does matter who he picks
look first credit we're credits due to
RFK Jr he's pulling in as a third party
candidate 15.8% of the vote I mean
that's an enormous accomplishment but I
think it's safe to say if the Republican
National Committee has an opposition
research page against you as they do
with RFK probably won't be the VP select
however Trump has to make up for the
antics of the deep State Russia
collusion Hunter Biden laptop
misinformation we don't know what they
have planned so he needs someone who can
bring in Independence I'm just going to
throw a name out there someone like
Glenn yunan who Trump's only behind in
the state by three and he's up 24 so
that's not bad they get along I always
think about like whoever he picks they
have to get along I think so but Glen
yunan can do it look Biden's down 17 in
the state Glen yun's up 24 bring on that
guy yeah I like okay Scott Adams brings
up VI and it's because he believes it's
a perfect compliment to Trump in the
sense that VI explains Trump better than
Trump does he's like he's like he's like
Robin to Trump's Batman yeah because
that's really funny but it's true in a
lot of ways Trump's surrogates are more
on message than him like to be serious
it wasn't always like that no I was
going to joke and this is a joke and say
that it should be Kanye for
real but but he's made so many
anti-semitic comments he's now president
of
Harvard it's I was like halfway to a
joke and I'm like he's got a job uh
listen if you want theories okay in the
era of identity politics I think he does
need a woman of color I would say
Elizabeth Warren
oh I saw that coming like a frisbee in
the desert that was just coming when you
said women of color we owed them one uh
but no I I mean I think it's substantial
but what's important is it doesn't
matter who he puts on the ticket I think
to prove a point he should almost
consider a Centrist
Democrat no I'm not even kidding like
even like he would kill us for saying
this but our mutual friend Harold Ford
Jr oh I'd love that just to get him off
the five though I like it
for dare I'm kidding but I no no but but
I like it for the country because I'd
like somebody would be a great president
he'd be phenomenal I I I believe that I
would actually work for him me too and I
would also laugh every day cuz the
Democrats would call him racist Hitler
know who's this white supremacist old H
so true all right up next is it funny
when a millionaire begs for money hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else